[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: I am
pleased to welcome
to the platform the
Honorable Alfred E. Vellucci,
mayor of the city of Cambridge,
and Dr. A. Bartlett Giamatti,
president of the National League
of Professional Baseball Clubs,
and former president
of Yale University.
Dr. Giamatti will
now give the address.
[APPLAUSE]
GIAMATTI: Good morning.
I know that this
occasion is a solemn one.
It is meant to celebrate the
graduates, meant to affirm us
and our commitment to
seeking the truth, meant
to figure forth the
institution's role as conveyor
of that common life
we call civilization.
I've thought much
on our institutions
for learning, our universities
in the last two years,
and today I want to
share with you, if I
may, some of those ruminations.
Specifically, I wish
to ruminate on what
it means to be a university
president, which I once was.
What does this have to
do with you graduates?
Well, aside from
enriching this moment
and of course, your
lives in general,
my ruminations will
eventually prove
to be splendidly relevant.
Being president of a
university is no way
for an adult to
make a living, which
is why so few adults
actually attempt to do it.
It is to hold a mid-19th
century ecclesiastical
position on top of a
late-20th century corporation.
But there are those
lucid moments,
those Joycean epiphanies
that occur and lay bare
the numinous beyond and give
us the essence of it all.
I had those moments.
They were all moments of
profound and brilliant failure,
but string those moments
of defeat into a strand
and you have the pearls of
an administrative career.
Six months between being
named president of Yale
in December of '77 and
taking office in July of '78,
I had ample opportunity
to receive advice.
I listened to many people.
I learned for instance,
for the first time
about the corporate world.
I learned that because
the corporate world is
only interested in
quarterly results,
it talks a great deal
about long-range planning.
It was very clear to me that
Yale needed some of that too.
We needed a policy.
I, of course had no policies.
I had a mortgage,
and I had one suit,
but I had absolutely no policy.
So I cast about.
I solicited data and forecasts
and projections and models.
I did something called
a comparative study.
I did longitudinal studies.
I made a flowchart, and I fired
four management consultants.
I went in search of policy.
[CHEERING]
You got it.
I was trying to find what
it was Yale needed most,
wanted most, and
would most contribute
to enhancing our
quality, and making me
what I knew now I was to
be, which was a manager.
Well, one night in April of '78
I was in my garage, actually.
I was trying to memorize the
trustees names, particularly
the ones I'd met.
And I was crouched between the
lawnmower and some snow tires,
and I wrote a memo.
It was the first time
I'd ever written.
On July 1, 1978, which
my first day in office,
I issued the following memo
to an absent and indifferent
university.
And it read as follows--
"To the members of the
university community.
In order to repair
what Milton called
the ruin of our
grandparents, I wish
to announce that henceforth, as
a matter of university policy,
evil is abolished and
paradise is restored."
Well, the reaction
was fascinating.
Four young members
of the faculty
in comparative literature
wrote an open letter
to the New York Review of Books
proving the Milton was not
talking about evil in
Paradise Lost, he was in fact,
talking about irony and the
patriarchal abuse of power.
There was a junior
in Yale College, who
was doing that summer,
a leveraged buyout
of a Tastee-Freez
in East Hampton.
She wrote me a very
gracious letter,
and said she understood that
one had to have a business plan,
but she hoped I
didn't change things
too much before she graduated.
Of course, there was the
alumnus in New York on Yale club
stationery who
wondered why the heck
we always had to get
so far out in front.
In September, an undergraduate
extracurricular activity
in New Haven called
the Yale Daily
News wrote the first
editorial about my memo.
It's opening
sentences were these.
I remember them.
"Giamatti's administration
is off to a miserable start.
Rather than giving us
control over our lives,
or at least addressing
concerns of students,
such as the crying need for a
student center so we can make
friends, or any of the other
myriad of injustices that
riddle the fabric of the
quality of life here,
new administration is
insensitive and repressive
and the future bodes awful."
And that was one of the best
written of the news editorials.
But to be fair, of course,
it was also the first.
Well, since the
students were back,
and this Daily
News is publishing,
the major media outlets
now had a source for news,
because student
stringers went to work.
In a small article byline
special to the New York Times,
the country's newspaper of
record misspelled my name
and said, a Harvard professor
had found a letter from Milton
to his parents in
[INAUDIBLE] library.
The Washington
Post ran a picture
of the memo in
the style section,
and wrote a sidebar in a box
quoting an FDA lawyer, who
asserted that evil had been
abolished three years earlier.
The regulations
that, after all have
been printed in the
Federal Register,
and nobody he knew in Washington
thought evil was bad for you
in any case.
The Wall Street Journal
wrote a very pithy editorial,
pointing out that fat, liberal,
effete, Marxist-oriented
eastern universities,
and Stanford too,
were all in a plot to
undermine the republic
and free enterprise.
Quote, "What we need,
they said in the journal,
is not more talk about evil,
but some decent courses
in risk arbitrage.
George Will wrote
another column citing
Montesquieu, Thomas Aquinas,
Locke, and Ernie Banks.
William Buckley said Milton,
quote "is all very well,
but it is typical of
President Giamatti and his ilk
to cite a secular
authority on evil
as if, of course,
those who have passed
any time down in the
agora, or out on the Rialto
needed an authority to know
the palpability of evil
in all its camaraderie
and liberal camouflages."
[LAUGHTER]
Well, it goes on.
I won't go on.
As you know, a
university president
has a responsibility not only
for the internal workings
of an institution, but also
for external representation
and relations as well.
And of all the moments I
remember speaking to alumni
and visiting foundations
and corporations and mayors
and governors and et
cetera, et cetera,
the moment I remember best-- and
I just reminded President Gray,
I think we met in this office
that morning in Washington--
was the morning I saw
Congressman Phlange
from the third district of a
state that we will call grace.
Congressman's office-- let
me set the scene briefly--
is a series of dark
paneled warrens each
leading to the other.
And as one enters,
one sees on the wall
a framed poster of
the last major arts
festival held in the district,
which was August 17, 1937.
There are some chairs
at the table with copies
of Collier's, and a telephone
that doesn't call anything.
There is, of course no ashtray.
The first receptionist is
reading her high school
yearbook and drinking
a diet Sprite,
so I approach the other
one who is less busy
and I say, "Mr. Giamatti to
see the congressman, please."
She looks up and says, well,
he's either in the district
or on the floor.
They're not sure, while I
sit in the corner by a phone.
And suddenly, the inner door
opens and a middle-aged person
with eyeglasses, hung on a
green cord around her neck,
and carrying up an
appointment book,
a clipboard, a stack of
letters, a cup of coffee,
and a Snoopy lunchbox,
comes up to me and says,
he'll see you right now.
Please follow me.
And she takes me out the door,
down the hall to the right,
through the first
door we come to,
passed the word processor
and an empty desk,
down a short corridor filled
with overflowing waste boxes.
She goes sharp right, past
the young man methodically
shredding what looks
like mail, and then
into the congressman's office.
Well, the congressman is sitting
behind a huge desk, surrounded
by plaques and awards,
and trophies and pictures
and laminated scrolls, and
six autographed footballs.
There are easy chairs, a
chocolate colored wastebasket,
an American flag,
and a mother of pearl
paperweight the
size of a basketball
with Republic of China
written across the bottom.
Doctor, he says, how are you?
It's a pleasure.
Please sit down.
Can we get you some coffee?
What brings you to Washington?
He of course, has
not yet looked up.
I'd like to get a picture of us.
I'll find a photographer.
And suddenly, he's
gone, out the door,
and then he's back
with a photographer.
And with a tall,
slim woman, about 30,
in slacks, blue work
shirt, denim vest, boots,
her hair pulled back in a bun.
Doctor, he says, this is
Mrs. incomparable Worth,
my legislative
assistant for education.
She'll sit in.
A flash goes off.
The photographer leaves.
And Ms Worth now speaks.
She says, we thank the NIH
cuts should go through.
We're not impressed with
your fatuous argument
that we can't change the rules
halfway through the game.
We think student aid only
benefits the rich and poor,
and rather than stopping
abuse, we would rather
do away with everything.
We don't believe in a federal
science facilities fund,
or in fact, in the
non-profit postal subsidy.
And given what they teach
in comparative literature,
we think it would be the
height of fraud and abuse
to fund the humanities.
We intend to uncap retirement,
cap technology transfer,
cut the NSF, get rid of
the Library of Congress,
and slash the Health Manpower
Act, because we want to get
this country moving again.
Well, congressman beams, and he
says, doctor, let me tell you.
It's an honor having you here.
We've got a college
in the district.
They do a wonderful job.
The education is marvelous.
Look what it made
the country today.
We've got a huge deficit on
balance trade, a weak dollar,
corruption in church and state,
although separated, of course.
It's great to see you.
Anything I can do,
just let me know.
Well, I go back out.
I go past the young
man shredding,
past the waste baskets, past
the silent word processor.
I'm finally in the hall.
I had not said a word.
But I had done
what I came to do,
which is I had my picture
taken, I'd seen a staffer,
I'd met a congressman, and I'd
heard all the issues touched
definitively.
I felt that our
system is working,
and the visit remains
in the mind as a pearl.
There's only one other moment
that I want to share with you.
It's a brief, but
glistening session.
Not long before I
left in '86, with
a university-wide,
community-based, self-selected
group called the Standing
Committee on Special Interests.
This committee is the
special interest group
that convenes to pursue a
special interests if there's
no preexisting special interest
group empowered to pursue
that special interest.
It monitors public utterances
to see who might be offended,
and then it takes
offense if no one else
has the time or inclination.
It watches power structures,
it petitions for redress,
it gathers, rallies,
assembles queries,
it blockades, occasionally
it even sincerely,
with a good heart,
assaults in a good cause.
It is an extraordinarily
hard working group.
It's never at rest.
Recently, it had
taken up the cause
of the inequality of income
distribution in North America,
the preservation of all
stained glass window at Yale,
and women's volleyball.
Well, I was summoned to meet
this standing committee.
I said I'd meet them in
a trustee room near where
I had my office.
They said they weren't sure
they could all fit in the room.
I said they could
send delegates.
They said they didn't trust
each other enough to delegate
any of their number.
And I said, well,
it's up to you.
They canceled.
Some clergymen in
the city immediately
petitioned on their behalf.
I caved in.
And when they finally arrived,
there were only seven of them.
I said, what could I do?
There's a long silence.
What's the issue?
I was baffled.
And finally the
spokesperson said,
we're really very sorry
to come to you like this,
but we are deeply concerned that
no one in the administration
is paying any attention to
the most pressing problem
of our time, which is
the problem of evil
and the restoration of paradise.
But I said, we
tried to solve that.
I sent out a memo years ago.
Well, we weren't here years
ago, said the spokesperson.
We're here now.
What can we do to
make it better?
And in fact, we
talked into the night.
I suppose in some ways, this
conversation and my versions
of the other conversations,
are variations
on that serious and
splendid conversation
that is any great university
anywhere in the country.
University today is very
different from the one
25 years ago, or 50, or
100 or 250 years ago,
and yet it is not different.
Tough as they are, they are
still fragile institutions.
But at heart, they are still
a constant conversation
between young and old, between
students and among faculty,
between faculty and students,
a conversation between past
and present, a conversation
the culture has with itself
on behalf of the country.
University lives
through all its voices,
and the conversation
does not stop there,
nor does each of our
conversations with whatever we
took away stop either.
It is perhaps, the sound
of all those voices
over centuries overlapping,
giving and taking
that is finally the
music of civilization,
the sound of human beings
shaping and sharing mooring
ideals to reality and making
the world for all its pain work.
The university is the place
where the mind learns first
how to make ideas which is the
mind's most durable product.
University is neither a
paradise, nor the worst spot
we've ever been in.
It is a good place,
which continues to want
to make our children better.
But its essence is
that give and take,
that civil conversation
in its innumerable forms.
When that conversation,
the to and fro of ideas
is stymied or
foreclosed or frozen,
when the questing
for truth is told
that it must cease because
there is only one truth
and it is complete, then the
institution in its essence,
is chilled, and its
life threatened.
The enemy of the
university is finally
not dissent, not disagreement,
not disagreeableness Gentility,
after all is the mark of a
great finishing school, not
a great university.
University doesn't
care for the genteel.
It cares for the blood
and sinews of ideas,
and non-coercive combat
with other ideas.
I suppose the non-coercive
quality is fundamentally
the key.
It's a combat that doesn't
seek to take a life,
but seeks to add
energy, passion, logic,
and commitment to the open
life of the mind in the service
of a more just society.
That's basically the nature and
purpose, the norm, the guiding
principle for all of us.
The deniers of left or
right, the diagnostician
for whom all
illnesses is similar,
because all cures are
identical, the purveyors
of an ism, the dealers and
system, the myopic for whom all
the world's pain
is simply reduced
to their cause, the simplifiers
who tell you that they're
idealistic because they boil
life down to a bumper sticker
or a T-shirt maxim,
the reductionist
who pretend to global
concerns so as to promote
a personal preoccupation.
These are in some
ways the enemies
of give and take, of debate,
disagreement of dissent,
the shouters who want it now
care of nothing for exchange,
for connection, for each of us
each to each working it out.
What must be fluid
so that each of us
has the freedom to promote
another's freedom of mind
and spirit and
belief, they would
freeze, catching us all in
the amber of their dogma.
Some ways they are the subtlest
enemies of the university,
of the life of the mind, not
because they win the day,
but because they remove
themselves from debate.
They force us into us and them,
fragmenting precisely when they
most hunger for solidarity,
splintering the very sense
of community they ache to form.
You've encountered
this impulse here.
You would have in any
university or college,
and you will certainly
in the wider world.
So all I learned in the
university, my graduating
friends, it is worth passing
on to you is simply this.
Do not write off the dogmatists.
Do not acquiesce in
the apocalyptic style.
Insist on conversation, even
when it is not proffered.
Have the courage to
connect, the courage
to strive to keep the shouting
down and the conversation open,
because I think only
in that way eventually
will equality of sexes and races
and opportunity finally come.
Only that way will
the homeless get
housed and the hungry fed
and the poor will get work
and will the city be rebuilt.
To have the moral courage,
to avoid the selfishness
of self-righteousness,
and to assert positively
the need we each of
us has for the other,
that is the real
work of humankind.
It has begun here,
and it will, I know,
be carried out into a life that
will remember how inhumane it
is to leave another alone.
Good luck.
[APPLAUSE]